Are you really in love with writing or
have you just got a crush on the idea of
being a writer? The reality is romantic
notions of what it means to be a writer
rarely match the daily grind. But after
building my career in the world of
writing, I discovered that there's a big
difference between calling oneself a
writer and actually getting writing
done. And between the wish and the
thing, there stands only one obstacle.
Some call it resistance. others writer's
block. But to overcome it, we are going
to look at it right in the face and call
it by its true name, fear. So, in this
video, I'm going to share with you eight
simple tried andrue tips that genuinely
helped me overcome the fear of writing
that we all go through and that'll
hopefully help you transform from
passive consumer to productive writer.
And if you're new here, my name is
William. I'm an English professor and I
help non-fiction writers write well. So,
if you want to learn about the art and
science of expert writing, be sure to
grab my free newsletter, Writer Science.
Link is down below the like button. In
order to understand these eight
strategies, it's important to point out
just how weird it is that in this world
of writers, we spend so much energy
talking about strategies for how to get
writing done. Like, you don't see this
in any other profession. Teachers don't
talk about how hard it is to get
teaching done. We just show up, do the
work, and leave. And when you really get
down to it, I think this whole genre of
writing routines and tactics all comes
down to managing the real problem that
we all have, fear. There's an old joke
about a guy who goes to a doctor and
says, "Doc, it hurts when I do this."
And the doctor says, "Well, stop doing
that." And sometimes I just have to
think about taking that advice. you
know, just write the safe stuff that
nobody can criticize. It would make
everything so much easier. So, the
question is, why do we keep doing it?
Why do I stop doing the thing that
hurts? I mean, it's not like this is
something that's unique to writing.
Whenever I sit down to write emails or
text messages, I don't feel fear. And
whenever I worked as a copywriter, I
never felt this way about writing
product descriptions. I mean, they can
be boring, but they didn't make me worry
that readers are going to hate me. So,
it's only when I want to write something
that actually connects with people that
this fear sets in. Anytime I want to
write something that makes them think
differently or helps them solve a
problem or just feel less alone. But the
fact is that ambition is why I started
writing online in the first place. And
without it, I'd just be adding more
noise. And I don't really think any of
us want to do that. And so what that
means is everything that is weak inside
of me is fighting against this ambition,
this writing. That's the part of me that
wants to scroll social media instead of
writing. The one that whispers, "Nobody
cares what you think." And the part of
me that wants to give up and just
consume other people's content forever.
Now look, your fears might be different,
but here's what I know. Every writer
who's worth reading is afraid of
something. Most people who talk about
starting a newsletter or writing a blog
never actually do it. And the ones who
do often quit after a few months when
they realize how hard it is to keep
going in public. But the writers who
make it aren't always the most talented
ones. They're just the ones who figured
out how to live with their fear and keep
publishing anyway. So, how do you do
that? How do you keep showing up when
everything inside of you wants to hide?
Well, as everyone knows, it's helpful to
set a schedule. But how often should you
write, when should you write, and how
many words per day? When William Faulner
was being interviewed by the Paris
Review, they asked him whether he writes
every day or only when he's inspired.
And Faulner said, "I only write when I'm
inspired. Fortunately, I'm inspired at
9:00 every morning." And that's a great
line, but it's worth reflecting on
because, well, look, if you only write
when you're inspired, you're never going
to get it done. You know, I once read a
story about a guy who was trying to quit
smoking and he had tried all the
different tactics, you know, the patch
and hypnotism and and read all the books
and everything. He would quit smoking
and then something stressful would
happen and it was always when something
stressful would happen that he would
start smoking again. And so he realizes
that there is this kind of backs stop to
his quitting smoking. I'm going to quit
smoking so long as nothing stressful
happens. But if you think about it, what
kind of a life is that? Like if you were
going to live the least stressful life
possible, that would be one in which
both of your parents die. So in other
words, you're never going to have an
unstressful life. And so therefore,
you're never going to quit smoking by
that logic. So his epiphany was that the
only way to quit smoking is to never
smoke again. And apparently that worked
for him. And I think the same thing
holds true for writers because like if
your rule is I'm only going to write so
long as there's nothing more important
to do. Well, good luck with that because
there's always going to be something
more important than writing. Writing is
probably the least important thing that
one could possibly be doing. And so in
order to reframe the way that we think
about writing, I think what you need to
do is invent the person who can do the
writing. And so I remember listening to
an interview with the Canadian author
Sheila Hedi who spoke about this. Not
inventing the book, but inventing the
person who writes the book.
>> Book that continues to be the most
interesting thing to think about for me
is not like the book itself, but what
needs to be done to get the book
written. What kind of person do you need
to be to write this book? In what ways
do you need to trick yourself in order
to write this book? I feel like that to
me is what I think the most about. I
think I don't actually think as much
about
plot or character. I like inventing the
self that makes that book.
>> And so, how do you invent the person who
can get writing done? Well, first you
need to plan for at least 2 months of
serious self-discipline. That's about
the amount of time that it takes to form
a new habit. Some studies say 3 months,
other studies say 6 weeks, but I think
the safest bet is to plan for at least 2
months of a serious self-discipline
where you're ruthless. Like you are
consciously shielding and protecting
this little seedling of a plant that
you're growing here, right? You want it
to have firm roots in the ground, but
right now it's a seedling and you need
to protect it from invasive species and
deer who are coming to nibble away at
this not only this writing habit, but
this alter ego that you're developing.
When should you write? Well, I recommend
writing in the morning. Other people
might come along with different
strategies, but look, this is what works
for me. Why does it work? Well, one,
willpower is like a muscle that gets
tired throughout the day. So you wake up
with a full tank and by evening you're
running on fumes. And so if you have
this reservoir of willpower when you
wake up in the morning, then use it on
this most important task, your writing.
And second, just getting writing done
early in the morning makes the rest of
your day feel like a victory lap. If
you've ever tried to enjoy your evening
when you know that you still have
something to write, it's impossible. But
if you finish your writing in the
morning, then everything else feels like
a reward. How long should you write
during these daily writing sessions?
Well, I think 30 minutes a day is
fantastic if you're busy. And if you can
manage an hour on your good days, then
you're doing great. During busy periods
when I'm teaching, I'll write in three
90minute sessions with breaks in between
just as I'm waiting between classes. But
honestly, the exact timing doesn't
matter as much as having a pattern. It's
just about finding something that works
for you. Some people like doing this
pomodoro technique where you use these
25 minute timers of, you know, focused
work and then a five minute break. Uh,
one tactic that I was using this winter
was uh this chess timer. This is
actually kind of cool. I'm not using it
so much these days, but but during the
winter holiday whenever I I was off from
school, I had a lot more time to write
during the day. And so I would use this
chest timer. I'd have uh 4 hours here
and 4 and 1/2 hours there. And my goal
was to have four hours of concentrated
uh writing time. And so I would just
have this timer going and it would
countdown and anytime I took the this
would be the the break timer. So anytime
I took the slightest break, I would just
flip that on and then I would have 4 and
1/2 hour uh as a break and uh 4 hours of
concentrated writing time. And so the
goal was just to count down the 4 hours
before the 4 and 1/2 hours counted down.
And so it kind of gified it for me. I
did that for a few months. It worked
great. But the point here is just to
find what works for you, but make it
consistent. Consistency is everything,
especially as you're developing this new
practice. It can be helpful to tell
people about your pattern, but be
careful whenever you announce it to
people. If you write about it on social
media or something like that or you tell
people in your life, don't focus on the
outcome. Like don't tell people that
you're writing a book. Tell people that
you are writing for 90 minutes a day.
I've seen people who announce kind of
grand projects they're going to be
taking on. And one I've heard that
there's this psychological phenomena
where your brain can't really tell the
difference between uh pursuing a goal
and announcing that you're going to
achieve it. And so you kind of like tap
out some of your emotional reserves or
something like that. Um, but also it can
just kind of make this feel like so much
bigger of an undertaking than it really
needs to be. So don't tell people what
your project is necessarily, but do tell
people about the habit that you're
starting to develop. Because I think
when you narrate your process to other
people, it becomes real like it stands
outside of your mood and motivation.
There have been times when I become
quite inspired and I set out big 90-day
writing goals for myself and inevitably
that peters out. So, it's quite helpful
to have somebody to hold you accountable
and it's great if they can follow up
with you and just kind of hold you to
it. How much should you write? Well, uh
word counts can be tricky. If it works
for you, that's great. I used to obsess
over word counts, but honestly, that
made me crazy. So now I just aim for
about two pages a day whenever I have
the time. And if that's not working for
me, I'll just focus on completing my
writing sessions. You know, Jerry
Seinfeld has whenever he was developing
his writing practice, he would set a
timer for I don't remember how long, two
hours or something like that. And his
rule was that he didn't have to write
during this time, but he couldn't do
anything other than write. And so if
you're really not hitting your writing
goals, if you really can't hit that word
count, then it's quite enough to just
sit in that undistracted time that's
reserved for writing. After a very short
period of doing nothing, if if you're
not allowing yourself to switch between
Twitter and and other distracting
elements, and you're just sitting there
with the writing, well, eventually
you're going to find something to write
about. Some days you're going to need to
revise what you've already written
before moving forward. And that counts,
too. We're going to talk about that a
little bit more, but we don't have to
think about writing as being this purely
novel output thing. Writing is
recursive. So, we'll come back to that
in a moment. But for now, let's just do
a little arithmetic. All right. So if
you can average just two pages a day
during these focused writing periods,
then you can finish a book draft in
about four to 5 months, right? So if you
want to write a,000 words a day, which
is about two pages, break that down into
250 words, you want four writing
sessions of 250 words. So if you have
these 25 minute writing sessions, that's
10 words a minute. So do you think that
in a 25minut writing session you could
handle writing one sentence or 10 words
per minute? If you can just break it
down to that level, write 10 words a
minute for 2 hours, that'll give you
enough for a rough draft of a
manuscript. But honestly, the best thing
about developing this daily writing
habit isn't just the pages that you
produce. It's actually knowing when
you're allowed to stop. Like if you
don't have these guard rails on your
writing practice, then it's very easy to
constantly feel guilty about all the
time and all the days when you could
have been writing more. But once you
establish this daily writing practice,
then it's very easy to know exactly when
you're finished. So, you just show up,
start your timer, 10 words a minute, hit
your time goal or your word goal, and
then you can enjoy the rest of your day
without this nagging voice telling you
that you should be working. That's why I
write in a specific place as well. It
just helps to build the habit, but it
also creates clear boundaries because
whenever I'm not in my writing space,
I'm not supposed to be working. I'm free
to actually live my life. But let's be
honest, whether you are writing for a
time goal or you're aiming for a word
count, there are going to be days when
you miss your goal. And we need to learn
how to manage those days because unmet
goals do not create habits. There's the
story about Victor Hugo who used to have
himself locked in his room and he
ordered his servants to only let him out
whenever he would pass the finished
pages, whatever his daily output goal
was underneath the door. That was the
only way that he could open that door.
And that might be a little bit extreme,
but it does illustrate this idea of the
goal being nonnegotiable. You do want
that kind of container for your
practice, something that will not let
you break out of it. But of course, you
don't want to be extreme about this. And
so, well, like him or hate him, I think
there's a really good take on this
principle that comes from Jordan
Peterson. Aim low. And I I don't mean
don't aim. And I don't mean don't aim
up. You can set yourself a goal that you
can attain and there's not going to be
much glory in it to begin with. It's one
step on a very long journey. And so it's
it and it starts to compound on you. So
a small step today means puts you in a
position to take a slightly bigger step
the next day. And then that puts you in
a position to take a slightly bigger
step the next day. And you do that for 2
or 3 years, man, you're starting to
stride. All right? So aim low. Like you
absolutely have to focus on small,
easily achievable goals. Don't plan to
write 2,000 words a day. Don't try to
write for 4 hours straight. Just focus
on slow and steady because your goal is
not to become this writing machine like
Stephen King who just has this
incredible output. Your job is to become
a goal meeting person. Remember you are
trying to invent the person who can get
writing done and that person meets
goals. In the book Atomic Habits, James
Clear tells this story of somebody who
is trying to develop the habit of going
to the gym. And for the first couple of
weeks, he actually would go to the gym
and not work out. He would go to the
gym, get into his clothes, and then pack
them up and go back home. And that's
because it wasn't about the exercise. It
was about transforming himself into a
gymgoing person. And so that's what we
really need to do at the beginning. It's
like start small. Can you have 15
minutes of totally focused time? Can you
write one sentence a day? Can you become
a goal meeting person? It doesn't matter
what the goal is because if you can just
meet these small goals, then it creates
this pattern of self-motivation and
reward that will keep you moving
forward. And look, missing the
occasional goal is not going to hurt
your habit building, but making a huge
deal out of it, that's what kills your
momentum. So, here's how you can start
making small goals and meeting them.
First, you've got to forgive yourself
immediately whenever you miss a day. You
don't abandon a diet because you had a
burger at a barbecue. You don't quit
learning guitar because you missed
practice on Tuesday. Don't let these
small lapses destroy the whole system.
Second, look forward. Like, if you can't
shake the guilt, just focus on meeting
today's goal and feeling good about it.
Third, do not add today's gap to
tomorrow's task. Like, if you had a goal
of 500 words and you only wrote 300
words today, that doesn't mean that you
have to write 700 words tomorrow. And I
think this is where goals and habit
systems get destroyed because it's a lot
harder to sit down to write 700 words
than it is 500 words. So if you carry
today's gap to tomorrow's goal, then
you're just going to make the habit that
much harder to start. Those extra words
have a way of spiraling out of control.
And pretty soon you're looking at a day
where you think you need to catch up by
writing 3,000 words. And you need to
find ways to celebrate whenever you hit
your targets. That could mean taking a
day off if you meet your writing goal.
Or you could just have a day where you
write, but you're not tracking anything
and so you kind of rejuvenate the
freedom that you feel in the craft. Some
of my best work has come from these
bonus days where I was just writing for
the joy of it. Finally, just go easy on
yourself. I don't know who needs to hear
this. Maybe I'm just talking to myself
with this one, but there might be others
of you out there who get this kind of
self-disiplining drill sergeant voice in
your ear. And I think we just need to
let go of all that and focus on building
the habit. Right? One danger in this
world of writing advice is that we can
try to trap ourselves in these routines
and you know brick our phone and be like
Hugo and lock ourselves in a room and
this can be very selfdestructive
and destructive to the practice as well.
Like I really think for this to work, it
has to be fun. And writing is fun. You
know, this whole video is talking about
the fear of writing and the pain of it
all. And so many writers really like to
talk about that loneliness and
isolation, but god for this to work, it
has to be fun, right? You don't hear
painters talking about the torment of
going to their studio and playing with
the paint. You don't hear sculptors talk
about it. Okay? The writing is our craft
and we need to find some joy and freedom
in it for this to be a sustainable
relationship. Like I don't want to live
in a world where part of me is
constantly screaming at another part of
me like some deranged drill sergeant.
And like this part of you that wants to
write, that's a good part of you. We
want to nurture that part of you. So you
don't want to turn your relationship
with that part of yourself and and with
your writing into this negative
experience. We really need to, you know,
as we're developing this habit system,
the point is through the habit to
discover the pleasure of writing. That's
why we're doing this. And so treat
yourself or that part of you like
someone you actually care about, someone
you want to nurture and somebody you
want to feel comfortable and and welcome
back the next time. And look, you're
going to get stuck. It's not a matter of
if, it's when. Sometimes you're going to
get stuck on the big picture. You might
be a few weeks into a project and
suddenly you think, "This is garbage.
The whole premise is flawed. I need to
start over." Other times you'll get
stuck in the moment of your writing
practice. You'll be sitting there
staring at a screen, feeling like you're
moving backwards, unable to write a
single line. And the solution to both
problems is exactly the same. Keep
writing. For those moments when you're
stuck in the middle of a writing
session, try this. Open a new document
and just start typing whatever's in your
head for 5 or 10 minutes. Usually, I'll
begin with something like, "Okay, I'm
stuck on this piece and I can't figure
out how to dot da da." Right? Whatever
you do, just don't stop typing. Just as
a quick analogy here, this is a practice
that I teach in my English as a foreign
language class. I work with students uh
here in Korea who have high knowledge of
English and low fluency. So, they know
they can pass tests, but they have a
hard time expressing themselves and they
get stuck just like you and I do. And
so, this is actually a very easy problem
to fix. And after a few of these writing
sessions, their uh this is fluency.
Their fluency increases exponentially.
And so what you do is you just set a
timer and you write anything that comes
to mind. Anything. You could repeat
yourself if you want. You could write I
don't know what to write about. If you
want, you could write I am trying to
write about this and I'm feeling stuck
about that. It almost doesn't matter.
The point is that it's just this fresh
writing session where your only goal is
to not stop typing. Now, of course, you
know, you want to be writing coherently.
You want to be writing sentences and not
just random. You're not just smashing
the keyboard, if you follow my drift.
But the point is that it doesn't matter
what you write so long as you don't stop
writing. And after 5 or 10 minutes of
this, you're often going to find your
way into a solution or at least that
you'll notice that your rambling
suddenly starts to veer into actual
focused writing and soon you're back in
the flow of your real project. And this
is an important substitution because
like my impulse whenever I feel stuck
writing is to get up, walk away from the
computer, go to the kitchen, and have a
spoonful of peanut butter. That's my
coping mechanism for this feeling of
being stuck. But now, whenever I feel my
legs starting to lift me out of the
chair, I just make myself sit there for
5 or 10 minutes more and write a few
random sentences. Nine times out of 10,
this breaks me through. Now, for bigger
problems, whenever you've lost faith in
the whole project, try this. Go back and
reread everything that you've written.
Now, don't just skim it. really read it
like you're encountering it for the
first time. And what I often find when I
do this is that it's better than you
thought or you're going to start to see
exactly where things are going sideways.
The problem here is that as a writer,
you're experiencing this text as a
writer. And so the way this process
works is you go back to the beginning
and experience it as a reader, going
through line by line, not just skimming
it, but really kind of reading it and
trying to follow the thought process of
the person who wrote it. Because as you
go through those sentences, you'll start
to encounter their your their thought
process and you'll start to see where
they went wrong. And once you've done
this, what you can do is write an
outline of what you actually have and
not just what you plan to write. Like as
you've been reading this, you're now
encountering it as a reader would. And
so you can start to describe the logic
that you see developing. This is going
to help you identify where the holes are
and the parts that you need to fill in.
And you'll start to see, oh, well, wait
a second. This part doesn't belong
there. and aha like then you start to
discover where the whole piece started
going sideways. So this is a matter of
changing your perspective from the
sentence level to the structure level
and once you can perceive that structure
in those larger units of discourse then
you can start to fix it. Like whenever
you get these macro problems where you
feel like a piece just isn't working.
That's usually not something that you
can resolve at the sentence level. You
need to resolve it at the structural
level. And so what this practice lets
you do is start to identify the
structure and you can start to see where
things aren't really fitting together in
these larger units of discourse. Now, if
you've tried both of those techniques
and you're still stuck, then it can
often be helpful to find somebody to
talk through it with. And this is where
a lot of us mess up. We only want to
show our work when we're proud of it.
And in my writing consultations, I can
often tell when writers are struggling
because they start avoiding certain
parts of feedback. Like their work isn't
going well. So, they start to feel
guilty about that and they want to solve
everything before anyone sees it. But
that's like going to the doctor only
when you're healthy. Like, if you don't
share your struggles, then nobody can
help you through them. So, you want to
find people whose opinions you can trust
and who can give you the kind of advice
that actually helps. Sometimes that can
be a writing group. And if you have one
of these, then count yourself really
lucky. But I've got to say, like
whenever these groups get too big, like
more than three or four people, the
advice generally gets a little bit too
polite and too vague. The best is
sharing one-on-one if you can find
somebody to do it. This can be close
friends or just anybody who will tell
you the truth. But above all, the point
here is just to not give up. We writers
have evolved beyond basic
procrastination. We're not binge
watching Netflix or scrolling Tik Tok
for hours. We're more refined than that.
No, no, that won't do. We have moved on
to the advanced stuff. Call it virtuous
procrastination. You know what I'm
talking about. Cleaning the house
instead of writing, organizing your
desk. These things feel productive, so
they don't trigger the same guilt as
obvious time wasting. But the truth is,
if writing terrifies you, then cleaning
your house feels like a vacation. Ah,
yes, it's the messy desk that stopped me
from writing. The dishes in the sink,
that's what'll get me writing. But the
fact is that you probably created that
mess unconsciously to avoid sitting down
at your computer. The sneakiest form of
virtuous procrastination is work that
feels important. And so the appeal here
is obvious. These tasks make you feel
productive and they have deadlines and
clear outcomes which is a lot better
than the kind of vague neverending toil
that we have whenever we're writing.
Like writing by contrast it makes you
feel uncertain and vulnerable. And until
the piece is done it's not really
serving anybody else except for you and
your vision. If you're an indie writer,
then nobody's demanding that you publish
that piece today except you. And you are
the easiest person to convince
otherwise. And since you're a oneperson
business, marketing and writing are both
part of building your platform. So, it's
easy to convince yourself that spending
3 hours on your Instagram strategy or
catching up on the news on Twitter is
just as valuable as writing, but it's
not. choosing the easier task because it
feels safer and it mitigates your fear
of writing. I swear my job as a writing
coach is like 90% psychology. And so, of
course, all of these things are part of
your business. And I'm not going to say
here that you should neglect them. Do a
decent job with the business stuff, but
don't forget what you actually want to
be known for. You want to be known for
your business strategy, your SEO. No,
you want to be known for your ideas, for
your voice and your perspective. And
that only comes from one place, sitting
down and getting writing done. But the
flip side of this problem is just as
dangerous. That's writers who can't stop
working on their projects. These writers
get stuck in endless research and
revision cycles because they're
terrified of putting their work out
there. So, as long as it's not finished,
it can't be judged. Oh god, I went
through this so much in university and
professors would always give me
deadlines. I just need a few more days
and then my term paper will be perfect.
But I swear that's like giving a drunk a
drink. And the logic here is quite
clever because as long as more research
could be done, then the work is still in
its perfect potential. You know that
flawless piece that you have in your
imagination, it stays there crystallized
instead of coming into the world in its
flawed form. So look, whatever you're
working on, it's not your magnum opus.
It's just your next work. And one thing
I've been discovering in this practice
of writing and making videos online is
that letting it go and having it be
evaluated, as painful as that moment is,
will teach you so much more about
writing than another month of polishing.
Now, look, you're going to
procrastinate. You're human. You're
going to find creative ways to avoid the
hard work all the time. But the goal is
getting better at catching yourself
sooner. And full transparency, of
course, I still procrastinate. Usually I
do it by reading too much or letting
admin tasks eat up my time. But the only
difference is that I recognize it
faster. Now, and I have habits that pull
me back to the actual writing. One of
the best tools here is talking to other
writers about how your work is going. In
my case, I have a colleague that I can
talk to. And it's just so funny. Like
the lies you tell yourself to avoid the
fear of writing just sound ridiculous
whenever you say them out loud to
someone else. Like, "Hey, how'd that
newsletter go last week? Oh, I can't I
couldn't work on it because I need to
redesign my website first. Oh, I'm not
ready to publish it because I haven't
done enough research." Do you hear how
silly that sounds? Good. Now, go write
something. Ah, but you're still here,
aren't you? And you're still afraid of
writing. Well, a lot of people think
that the goal is to stop being afraid of
writing, but in this video, I'm saying
something completely different. I'm
saying any writing that aims to be great
will always be frightening. Like, if
you're aiming for greatness, if you're
aiming for that great vision of
something that you have in your mind,
that vision is going to challenge you to
do your best work and it forces you to
face the possibility that you might not
live up to those dreams. And so that
fear of writing is not going anywhere. I
mean, I suppose maybe somewhere out
there there's a writer who feels no
fear, but I imagine fearless writing as
complacent writing. And look, to be
frank, there are a lot of writers out
there, you can probably think of a few,
who are just too confident and too sure
of themselves to be surprised by any new
ideas. So these supremely confident
writers, the ones who never feel fear
before they hit publish, there's nothing
you can learn from them. And that's the
reason why no one fears writing emails
because they don't aim for perfection.
They just aim for information transfer.
But the best writing, the kind of
writing that I think you and I are
aspiring to is that which generates new
knowledge. It causes a a a surprise
discovery in the writer and it's written
in such a way to deliver that discovery
as a gift to the reader. That kind of
writing is always going to be driven by
fear. And I don't think we're ever
really going to extinguish that fear.
It's tied in with the aspiration of
writing something true and valuable. So
instead, what we need to do is make fear
an ally, right? So if you really think
about this fear as a character or like
an animating force within you, then you
want to not fight it, but instead use it
as a signal. Oh, there's this great
quote by a Buddhist nun named Pemma and
she says something like fear is a signal
that you're moving closer to the truth.
All right? So, whenever you feel that
fear, don't fight it, but use it to show
you the opportunities in your work. All
right? And whenever you're stuck and
you're trying to break through it in one
of these quick writing sessions, what
you can ask yourself is, what am I most
afraid of here? What scares me about
this paragraph? Why am I stuck here? I
now have an image of like somebody on
the beach with, you know, one of those
beach comrs with a metal detector,
right? Like fear should be the beep beep
beep that you're you're you're
uncovering something valuable here. And
so you should write about that fear and
and follow its thread because underneath
it like it's linked to something. It's
linked to something important. Instead
of seeing it as an obstacle, imagine it
pointing to the most interesting problem
in your work. All right. Here's another
way that you can use fear in your
writing. Keep enough of it alive to make
your writing interesting. Like we always
say writing is thinking. Writing is
thinking. But if that's true, like if
you really believe that, then it's also
true that if you sit down and you know
already what your conclusion is, then
what's the point of writing that?
There's no discovery. There's no thought
in it. The idea is dead on arrival.
Maybe this is just a personal
preference, but I prefer writing that
stays open to learning something new.
Now, sometimes whenever I'm writing and
I'm a few pages into a piece, I'll
stumble onto a really good idea, one
that would be a perfect ending for the
whole piece. Now, if this ever happens
to you, I think the instinct is to save
it and then build towards it. You know,
writing confidently, knowing where
you're going to finish the piece. But
these days, whenever that happens, I
force myself to write that idea down
immediately right there on the page. And
so instead of saving this best piece for
last, I just kind of position it as it
occurs to me. And this forces me to find
something even better for the ending. I
mean, that's the rule, right? Like your
your best idea can't be buried there in
the middle. And so it's a little
challenge to myself like if this gem of
an idea is positioned there in the
middle of a piece then I have to keep
thinking and keep discovering. This kind
of writing is like wy coyote you know
running off the cliff and then building
the bridge frantically just ahead of my
feet. Now there is a piece of writing
advice that we need to address and that
is about being concise. Every writing
guide out there will tell you to cut
ruthlessly. Use fewer words. Trim the
fat. And this advice isn't wrong, but it
misses something crucial. You cannot
worry about concision when you've just
started writing. Think about it like
money. Whenever you're broke, buying
someone lunch feels impossible because
you barely have enough to feed yourself.
But whenever you're rich, you can pick
up the check for everyone at the table.
It's the same thing with writing. You
can only afford to cut when you have
plenty to spare. Like cutting 10 pages
from a 20page draft is a disaster, but
it's not really a big deal to cut 50
pages from a 200page manuscript. So I
found that if you start following this
advice of concision and pruning too
early, then you're going to slow
yourself down and miss the chance that
one of those wordy paragraphs contains
the next big idea. like this advice
about concision. It's a good point of
writing style, but I think in practice
it becomes this dangerous psychological
pattern where it becomes almost like
self-punishment disguised as virtue.
It's almost like writing anorexia. You
know, you're holding yourself to these
impossible standards that nobody else
believes in. No matter what you're
writing, I think it's really important
to write without knowing exactly how
things are going to turn out. You really
got to let yourself learn as you go and
follow ideas wherever they lead,
wherever they come from, who knows. This
is a mode that I call shifting between
the artist and the architect. The artist
is just a channel for these ideas to
come through. And it's really important
to give them life and give them space
and just get out of their way. And then
eventually you can step back as the
architect and see how everything hangs
together. Some pages aren't going to fit
in the final shape, and that's fine. But
by that point, you'll have so much
material that you can afford to be
generous with your cuts. Now, one piece
of advice I came across recently is that
there needs to be a separation between
writing and revision. First, you write,
then you fix what's broken. But as
anybody who actually understands writing
can confirm, that's completely
backwards. If you want to create
something meaningful, real writing is
recursive. Whenever I work, I pause
after each section or paragraph, read
back what I've written, and this helps
me see what I've actually accomplished
and start mapping the shape of the whole
piece. But more importantly, it helps me
find my best ideas. Now, since I don't
really censor much in my first drafts,
my writing usually contains multiple
ideas. Some that are connected to
others, others that are just floating
around orphaned. And whenever I reread
and revise, I hunt for these strongest
thoughts and start building the
structure around those concepts. The
weaker stuff just gets cut or saved for
later. So this process of freewriting
and then hunting for the key ideas and
structuring. This creates a feedback
loop. The structure that emerges from
the revision shows me where the next
sections need to go. The closer I get to
finishing, the more I understand what
the piece needs to be complete. So,
here's what this means practically. If
you write this way, then revision isn't
something that happens after writing.
Revision is writing. The act of revision
creates the text just as much as those
first sentences that you put down. Most
people learn about editing and revision
in school as fixing whatever the teacher
marked as wrong. So correcting grammar
or maybe adding a paragraph here or
there. And I think that teaches you two
things. One, it teaches you that
revision is something that happens to a
static complete text. And two, it
teaches you that revision happens at a
separate moment from the writing
process. But real revision is dynamic.
It's discovering what you actually are
trying to say. And I'm going to go
farther and say that it might actually
be helpful to think of research in the
same way. Like I used to separate
research days from writing days, but the
more I think about it, the more that's
totally artificial. Some of your best
ideas might come from browsing, reading,
or just taking notes. And I think it's
only fair to treat those moments of
discovery as part of the writing process
itself. So consider giving yourself
credit for research as part of your
writing practice. Include it in your
goals and your habits. And if you need
to spend 2 hours reading and taking
notes, I think that counts as writing
time. But be careful. Research is also
one of the classic forms of virtuous
procrastination. So what's the
difference between productive research
and procrastination? Well, I think it's
whether the research is moving your
current project forward or if it's just
making you feel busy. When you're
reading to understand something
specific, something that your piece
needs, that's writing. But when you're
reading just because you're trying to
avoid the negative feelings connected to
the blank page, that's avoidance. So, I
think the key here is just integration.
Writing, researching, revising, they're
all part of the same idea generation
process. They all involve discovery and
they all move your work forward. So stop
thinking of revision as cleanup duty and
start thinking of it as the place where
your real ideas emerge. Finally, last
point, I just need to say that, you
know, this genre that we're kind of in
here on writing YouTube, this genre of
writing advice, it's really like
self-help for writers. We read guides to
writing by Stephen King or Annie Dillard
because we think that it has the secret
that we need to get unstuck. But the
simple fact is that the thing that's got
you stuck is fear. So take this advice.
I'm going to be honest with you. Most of
the people won't actually try any of the
things that we've shared in this video.
I've worked with writers who listen to
these ideas with genuine excitement.
They nod along and say, "Yes, yes,
writing every day. 30 minutes sounds
perfect. Yes, I'm totally going to do
that." And they don't. And I think this
happens for two reasons. First, they
don't quite believe I actually do these
things myself. And so, they think this
advice is maybe for beginners, for
people who don't have their act
together. And since their goal is
eventually to not need systems and
habits, they figure that they should
start practicing the advanced stuff
right now. But of course, this is
completely backwards. Whenever I'm
working on something important, I do
everything that I've described here
exactly as I've described it. And this
really is my grownup professional
writing practice for whatever it's
worth. I'm not making up training wheels
for amateurs. And the second reason why
I think they don't follow this advice is
that following it consistently is hard.
As we said at the beginning, it takes
about 2 months to build an automatic
habit. That's two months of serious
willpower and discipline with constant
opportunities to backslide, get caught
in emotional traps, or just get taken
over by new priorities. So, I get it.
This stuff is hard. But here's what you
need to know. It does get easier. Not
easy, but easier. the habits become more
automatic and the resistance that you
feel becomes less strong and you start
to trust that the process works. So the
only advice that I can give you is to
trust yourself enough to try it. Start
small. Pick one thing and commit to it
for a week. If that works, try another
week. Don't let small lapses convince
you to give up entirely. And please be
good to yourself. Make friends with your
anxiety and your fear. Don't fight them.
That's part of you and they're trying to
tell you something. And remember that
every professional writer who you admire
has felt exactly what you're feeling
right now. They might not admit to it in
their author interviews in print, but be
assured they do. And the only difference
between the professional writers and the
ones who want to write is that they kept
going. So start small, really small.
Write a comment below and let me know
which one of these tips you're going to
try. A thousand words a day. It's not
much, but it's honest work and should
hopefully get you started writing today.
But you might be tempted to speed this
up by outsourcing the work of writing to
AI. And while that does punch up your
word count, it's also going to dilute
the value of your writing. So watch this
video next because it's going to give
you my plugandplay system for writing
valuable non-fiction without AI. So be
sure to go check it out.